hello everyone welcome to another
episode of good gaming news which is a
mostly weekly gaming news show where I
try to cover all of the good news
surrounding video games that came out in
the given week because there's already
enough negative news everywhere all the
time and it gets a lot more views but we
don't need any more of it so this week
we are starting with a story about one
of my favorite video game franchises I
am extremely excited about this on
behalf of myself and other people um so
the news is this is from at Witcher game
on Twitter and it says we're thrilled to
reveal that together with Fool's Theory
we're working on remaking the Witcher
using Unreal Engine 5 codename Candace
Majoris which they had previously kind
of alluded to
um we want to do this right so please be
patient it's gonna be a while until we
can share more details um but yes the
Canis Majoris had been referenced on
their
um investor account previously the post
on their website says we are thrilled to
announce that The Witcher remake is
being being worked on that's right the
game that started it all is being
rebuilt from the ground up in Unreal
Engine 5. the game is currently in the
early stages of development at the
Polish Studio Fool's Theory where
veteran witch's series staff are
involved oh yeah as CD predict red are
providing full creative supervision The
Witcher remake is what you might know by
the code name Canis Majoris it's still
early and we want to ensure that the
game is created with the utmost carried
attention to detail therefore while
we're excited to share the news with you
we will want to ask for patience as it
will be a while until we start talking
about this project in detail
they had a studio at CD project said The
Witcher is where it all started for us
for CD projekt Red it was the first game
we made ever and it was a big moment for
us then going back to this place and
remaking the game for the next
generation of Gamers to experience feels
just as big if not bigger and I am super
excited about it because
I love the witches series
The Witcher one is just not that good
and that happens when it's the first
game that a studio makes
um it's it still has the essence of The
Witcher it builds a great foundation for
The Witcher 2 which I think is like
severely underrated but also not
necessarily that accessible like I love
The Witcher 2 I think it's incredible it
does storytelling things and I wish
other games would even consider like um
you can talk your way out of a boss
fight you just have to plan things
correctly and you can literally talk
your way out of fighting somebody uh
it's it's so so so cool but also like I
said not that accessible to newcomers in
that some of the systems are a little
more on the complex side but again I
absolutely adore it I I love it I think
it's such a good game uh The Witcher one
I don't love so much but I think that
there's still so much potential in it
again it did set a really really really
good foundation for The Witcher 2 and
obviously The Witcher 3 which is in my
top 10 games of all time I absolutely
love the Witcher 3. and part of the
issue with the which one is that um I
think it almost felt dated even at the
time that it came out uh so this is
putting a fresh skin on the weekend a
game in the series that I would
currently not recommend people play I
would still recommend people play The
Witcher 2. and giving it a refresh and
an update and hopefully it being like a
proper remake where we also get some
updated systems it's just super exciting
because again the essence is there it's
a game that I want to love
um but didn't resonate with that
strongly obviously as I said we probably
won't see this game or hear about this
game for a very long time but it is in
collaboration with Fool's Theory rather
than being taken on by a CD project
themselves so maybe it won't be the 10
years we've come to expect it might be
five and yes I know a significant number
of people on that team uh came from CD
Pro defense so they have the experience
to do it and it is also just
significantly easier to make a remake
than it is to make a brand new game and
that's not to say that it's easy it's
just that half the battle of making a
game is thinking about how things are
going to work or the level design or
what the systems are going to be like
half the time consuming parts of that
process probably more than half it's
like three quarters is thinking about
what things are going to be more so than
even executing on those things so that
workload is a bit smaller um but I'm
excited to see more I'm excited to learn
more I'm excited to find out like how
much they're remaking in I really hope
for like a Resident Evil style remake
where it's the same call game and it has
all of the beats that we love about The
Witcher and everything that we've come
to know and love about geralt but that
maybe the gameplay is more similar to a
Witcher 3 than to the original Witcher
though I also love the gameplay and The
Witcher 2 even though it is very
different
big fan wow I really need to make this
new logo smaller hang on there we go my
about that it's great news um we did
also get another really tiny update from
uh The Witcher account this week which
um Scotty the Healer here said speaking
of which any word on Witcher 3 4 next
gen and the official account replied
soon don't know what that means in terms
of this particular Studio to be honest
that could be a year but if it were
really really really far out or like
they hadn't at least had something
planned I the account just wouldn't have
replied so yeah just a couple of fun
updates for The Witcher fans out there
we are eating next up this is a pretty
unusual story
um but I don't know how many people will
be interested in this but I just found
it very cool
what a cool thing to happen so the story
is uh reported by Kotaku and says every
us PlayStation 2 game manual is now
scanned in 4k creating a complete set of
usps2 booklet scans took 22 years over
40 000 and a ton of passion the story
says let me move myself over
the story says physical game manuals are
hard to come by these days especially as
the industry begins to heavily lean into
Cloud streaming and digital first
infrastructures but if you remember
those good old times when game boxes
came with chunky pamphlets for you to
peruse before jumping into your recent
purchase a game's preservationist called
Kirkland seeks to preserve that
Nostalgia for Prosperity by creating
high quality scans of manuals of your
what an unnecessarily complicated
sentence you could have just anyway in
fact it says he's just finished
uploading his complete set of Us
Playstation 2 manual scans show all
files what a cool thing to do honestly
you've even got Barbie horse Adventures
wild horse rescue
two Devil May Cry
the fact that we can just do this
because somebody went through the effort
to upload these is the absolute coolest
oh man these are really high quality
scans too handling a PlayStation 2
format disk do not bend it crush it or
submerge it in liquids do not leave it
in direct sunlight or near a radiator or
other source of heat don't make Cry 2 is
best played with the dual shock 2 analog
controller
this is so rad the rest of this is
largely like a personal opinion on the
manuals and then we have a quote from
Kirkland the goal is to raise some
awareness for game preservation efforts
so many games growing up shaped how we
look at and experience the world of
course as we grow up we move to other
things but there are a lot of us who
have Nostalgia for these things and want
our kids to be able to enjoy what we did
the whole read the books your father did
do and there have been great efforts to
preserve games
vghf the strong Museum and Grassroots
efforts like m-a-m-e red dumb.org no
intro and cowering's good tools before
that which I always thought this is
great we're gonna have everything
preserved but without the manuals we're
not going to know how to play them they
said my process is horrible I pull the
Staples and run most everything through
my s-bon ds870 sheet fed scanner as a
die-hard perfectionist using a document
scanner it's disappointing for quality
but a necessity due to volume this must
have taken so long I spent seven months
scanning SNES manuals and only made it
to the letter e using three flatbed
scanners oh my God uh with this setup
I've been able to scan almost 75 000
pages in the last year alone
after the tedious work of scanning each
page Kirkland uses a bevy of apps like
Adobe Acrobat Pro Photoshop text pad and
PDF combiner Pro to get them as clean
and pristine as possible for uploading
them all to archive.org in both 2K and
4K resolution
I've spent entire summer vacation
scanning manuals only to discard them as
I've gotten better equipment or better
processes lots of late nights wow
Kirkland said that he dropped about 40
000 on his usps2 collection as he
methodically bought every US release
over the course of 22 years that's
that's actually very interesting that I
guess like that estimate there means
that it you're going to spend forty
thousand dollars to get every PS2 game I
grabbed new releases when they got down
to 20 for about the first 800 releases
then I started picking up you sports
games in good condition then it was
hunting down at the odd variants which
is never ending such an incredibly cool
thing to do he's also done it for every
us snazz manual in 2K and is currently
working on that in 4k and the Atari 2600
and Game Boy ooh as well as the original
PlayStation manuals
wow I really like this quote too he says
in a perfect world companies would step
up and release their original artwork
sent to the presses for preservation but
so many of those have been lost to
history and hard drives over time it's a
picture of his collection just such a
cool thing to do such a cool thing for
us to have access to just mad props to
Kirkland
um so unbelievably cool also I love that
this is where you work out my guy that's
that's next level respect next up I
wanted to address this pretty quickly to
be honest so if you didn't see the news
I very intentionally did not talk about
it when it first came out despite
definitely getting a lot of comments
from people here asking me to make a
video about it and I think I got a lot
of tweets about it um as well so if you
missed the story The synopsis that I'll
give you here I would give you a deep
dive but this is a good gaming news show
and this story sucks overall Helena
Taylor who is the voice actor of um
Bayonetta who I think has done an
absolutely fantastic job made a series
of videos asking people to boycott
Bayonetta 3 claiming that Platinum had
only paid her four thousand dollars or
sorry only offered her four thousand
dollars for the role and thus she
declined and Jennifer Hale was hired
instead obviously I reached out to
Helena for interview I emailed her and
asked if I could formally chat to her
about it rather than again making a
video or saying anything on Twitter as
it just seemed like something that
probably needed more context to me it
was clearly very impassioned and
um I don't know I think whenever you see
somebody uh call for for boycott you
probably need to hear all sides of the
story is my stance but obviously she did
not get back to me or declined to
comment so then some reporting from
Bloomberg uh who I believe got proof
suggested that in fact she was actually
offered I think more like fifteen
thousand dollars and she then had to
walk back her statement
um saying that she was only offered four
thousand dollars after she had declined
the role of Bayonetta and would have
been getting four thousand dollars to
voice a different character so Platinum
did try to reach out obviously that is a
very truncated way of telling you the
two sides to the story and the one thing
that I feel is very positive about it is
that
um it has brought a conversation into
the Limelight regarding how voice actors
are paid in the games industry for all
of the negativity surrounding it I do
feel like the highlights on how big some
of these franchises are and how little
comparatively the people voicing these
characters are paid is tremendous I
think the same can be said for most devs
I think most people on the actual Dev
teams
um deserve to be paid a lot more too
that is certainly not exclusive to voice
actors but if that's going to be the
facet of conversation that is struck up
I definitely feel like it's an important
one because these are also people who
especially if they're us-based often
have a very expensive education years
and years of work that they are trying
to pay off or have to work to pay off
you have no idea when your next job will
be and voice acting if you haven't
watched my podcast voice acting 101 uh
that's on this channel it dives into
this uh across various episodes I guess
so just play watch listen thanks to Troy
voice acting is not just reading lines
on a page let me be honest that's what I
do as a voice actor but that's because
I'm not very good at it it is working
with writers and the director to create
the character together the expertise
that actors offer is tremendous I wrote
something last year oh my God it was
this year it was just earlier this year
that Ryan Reynolds read and he read my
script verbatim word for word like
exactly what I wrote and I was like
Blown Away by it I was like oh you're
really good at what you do holy [ __ ] the
delivery even of the stupid jokes that I
wrote for him was so natural that the
best writer in the world is really only
as good as the actor that is cast in the
role there is no denying that Bayonetta
who has become iconic across a multitude
of of communities is Iconic and that
Elena Taylor is a huge part of that and
that you know you're kind of advertising
the game every event that you go to all
of the extra outside work that actors
have to do
their Public Image has to stay a certain
way for people to continue to align with
that character it's a lot of pressure to
be the public face of a character in a
way that often writers and directors
also aren't even and from every voice
actor that I know and I'm friends with
yeah these people are criminally
underpaid you'd be shocked how little
some voice actors get paid for
tremendous amounts of work that can
permanently damage parts of their body
their vocal cords obviously you don't
know when your next job is going to be
and your contribution though it may be a
lot smaller than the rest of the dev
team is so tremendous I don't know that
there should be a standard rate for
voice actors but I do feel like they
should be paid at least in accordance
with the success of a franchise if your
publisher is profiting millions
especially when you look at actors in
other Industries like TV and film it's
even more clear that voice actors are
being underpaid despite the work being
equally as challenging and equally as
important as to film and TV so I was
happy despite the negative circumstances
here the controversy surrounding this
whole story that again I didn't even
want to make a video go on and didn't
because it did seem like something to me
that needed more context I was happy to
see that conversation be there and
Prevail and I don't want to lose that
threat if you are watching this and you
stopped caring the minute that you found
out that what she said was uh misleading
at least that's how I personally took it
I employ you to consider that that is
still the case for a lot of voice actors
so this is the final message from
Platinum games um to kind of wrap this
whole thing up I think this was posted
October 20 at 8 43 PM it says a message
from Platinum Games who I love we at
Platinum Games offer our sincerest
appreciation to everyone who has
contributed to creating the Bayonetta
series over the years as well as the
community that has served as its
foundation we give our full support to
Jennifer Hale as the new Bayonetta and
align with everything in her statement
because of course Jennifer Hill the new
voice actress got a fair amount of shade
thrown at her we asked people to please
refrain from any further comments that
would disrespect Jennifer or any of the
other contributors to the series which I
think this is a really good statement
obviously handcrafted by someone who's
good at their job in PR which isn't
always the case in the games industry
but could not agree more strongly on on
the bottom of this here just leave
Jennifer Hale the [ __ ] alone as somebody
who lost out to a job because Jennifer
Hale was given the job I understand how
hard it is I get it when I was told that
they had to decide between me and
Jennifer Hale and we were the two I
understood
I knew what was gonna happen but she's
fantastic at what she does and um I have
no doubt that she will be working
incredibly hard to bring Bayonetta to
life and I think that this is just I
also respectful to Hannah Helena Taylor
and all of the work that she did in
creating Bayonetta that will serve as
the foundation for Jennifer Hale it is
still important despite all of this she
still did an excellent job with a
character that um I think could have
been easy to [ __ ] up and on the end of
this I'm in strong agreement let it die
we ask people please refrain from any
further comments that would disrespect
Jennifer Hale or any of the other
contributors contributors I'm speaking
so weirdly today to the series which
includes Helena Taylor obviously I just
agree agree Let It Die backlash has been
thrown at absolutely everybody so far I
think and if there is a conversation
worth continuing it is the one that
shines the spotlight on how a lot of
voice actors still are underpaid fifteen
thousand dollars probably still isn't
enough money for Bayonetta 3 but I don't
know the scale of the game to be honest
so yeah last but not least my friends
very exciting
we have an official launch trailer for
God of War Ragnarok the game is so close
to coming out I am so excited to watch
people play it I have confirmed from the
team that I am not allowed to play it I
mean I have already played it obviously
but I'm not allowed to stream or make
YouTube videos of it or talk about any
of my contribution to it whatsoever so
for anyone who has been asking me about
those things there will be absolutely
none of that I'm not allowed to but I'm
still gonna watch people play it I'm
very excited to see the reviews
just just excited in general so I
haven't watched this yet I don't know
what the launch trailer looks like so
let's watch it shall we
time is running out the prophecies say
femble winter leads to Ragnarok war is
coming
we don't really want war
all that blood on your hands and your
son's hands
fate only bind you if you let it
we will make our own destiny
yeah baby let's go I can't wait